[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Laurent Richard
vice-président du conseil départemental
des Yvelines délégués à la santé bonjour
bonjour alors on va on va parler
ensemble du déploiement de la
télémédecine dans le département mais
aussi des inquiétudes des yvelinois face
au désert médicaux alors justement
qu'est-ce que la télémédecine en quoi ça
consiste alors la télémédecine je dirais
il faut déjà la situer dans le cadre
d'une cabine de télémédecine puisque
c'est ce que nous pratiquons une cabinet
de médecine donc c'est une cabine qui
peut être située dans un lieu public
j'en parlerai après et qui qui va être
totalement confidentiel sonorisée bien
sûr et qui vous permet donc d'entrer en
contact avec un médecin que vous nous
choisissez pas personnellement mais que
un organisme quatre HD qui est qui est
l'opérateur qui qui met un train en
place les cabines de télémédecine du
département
vous vous propose
et qui lui-même vous commandera bien sûr
toute la consultation non seulement en
visio si je veux dire puisque en fait
face à face mais aussi grâce à 8 8 à 10
c'est 8 je crois 8 instruments de
consultation courantes qu'il a
habituellement dans son cabinet et qui
sont devant vous et qui vous permettent
et lui permettre effectivement de
mesurer tout ce qu'il a envie de mesurer
en fonction effectivement de la
consultation qu'il est attention de
faire après ce que vous lui dites voilà
c'est bien c'est la différencier aussi
de la téléconsultation la
téléconsultation c'est chez soi la
téléconsultation c'est chez soi ça se
limite à une visio ce qui est quand même
déjà peut-être une chose ça peut
rassurer très vite surtout quand on voit
un médecin qu'on connaît par exemple ça
peut être très rapide aussi mais là
c'est très différent parce que là vous
allez ensuite pouvoir avoir une
ordonnance enfin bref vous aurez une
consultation complète mais à distance
alors justement les patients se rendent
donc dans une cabine vous l'avez dit
pour être en communication avec un
médecin disponible on parle bien de
médecins il y a un opérateur qui gère
tout ça mais c'est bien un médecin qui
se retraite derrière bien sûr de de
vrais médecins qui souvent d'ailleurs
ont plusieurs
fonctions c'est-à-dire qu'en fait dans
la semaine ils vont peut-être aller dans
un hôpital une clinique qui vont avoir
faire des urgences et puis ils accordent
une journée ou deux ou trois enfin ça
c'est un peu à la carte entre
l'opérateur et puis ces médecins
et de préférence c'est ce que nous avons
voulu ce seront des médecins urinois ce
sont des médecins de notre de notre
territoire alors justement si le
département mais ce dispositif en place
c'est pour répondre à l'absence de
médecins sur le territoire entre 2010 et
2020 vous estimez à 20% la baisse de
médecin généraliste dans les Yvelines et
44% des médecins généralistes restants
sont proches de la retraite alors la
télémédecine semblait donc la meilleure
option finalement pour répondre à cette
désertification médicale oui ils ont des
chiffres d'ailleurs que validé par
l'URPS qui est le quel organisme
principal
représentant les médecins généralistes
et donc ça situe vraiment l'importance
du problème qui s'aggrave donc
maintenant avec l'arrivée à la retraite
des médecins existants et donc notre
intention effectivement c'est notre
première intention a été d'abord de
mettre en place des cabines des pardon
les maisons médicales
mais des maisons médicales les maisons
médicales on en met 22 dans les Yvelines
donc ça c'est un point essentiel si vous
voulez de de pour lutter contre une
désertification médicale mais là en
attirant de vrais médecins dans ces
enfin in vivo des médecins dans ces dans
ces cabinets et de façon effectivement
surtout dans les zones ce qu'on appelle
l'intervention prioritaire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui 100% du département est
en désertification des médicaments comme
presque 100% de la France d'ailleurs
parce que le mais il y a à l'intérieur
de ça il y a une graduation
supérieur pire si j'ose dire qui est
la zone d'intervention prioritaire et
c'est là qu'on s'efforce d'être à la
fois avec les d'abord avec les les
maisons médicales que de façon
volontariste nous avons mis en place
quand j'ai volonté c'est que c'est pas
dans les normalement dans les
compétences d'un département donc on
fait ça parce qu'on a senti que c'était
vraiment un sujet extrêmement urgent
pour les pour les Yvelinois et comme
nous avons des capacités
d'investissement grâce à une gestion
très très stricte au niveau
fonctionnement et et plutôt au contraire
généreuse pour les Illinois au niveau
investissement et bien on a décidé
d'investir dans le domaine de de la
médecine justement ce que vous dites
c'est pas la télémédecine ce n'est pas
la seule réponse apportée par le
Département les complémentaires et les
complémentaires c'est qu'elle va aller
dans les coins les plus reculés elle va
aller par exemple dans les quartiers
politiques de la ville où il y a déjà
des des
maisons médicales qui sont en cours mais
tous ne sont pas couvert immédiatement
donc là les cabines de télémédecine vont
venir en complément et j'irai même dans
une maison médicale à terme pour
l'instant mais ça on en a les 8
premières on les met dans des des
centres sociaux du département répartis
dans le territoire ou des sciences
médico-sociaux comme les PMI la
prévention Maternelle Infantile alors
donc
ça c'est les 8 premières et après ça se
déploiera ça peut aller même dans des
cabinets dans des maisons médicales ou
les médecins sont déjà eux-mêmes je
dirais complètement
complexe dans leur dans leur dans leur
planning et donc ils seront ravis
d'avoir ceci en complément pour dégager
sur des petites des petites disons des
des petites affections voilà quand on a
quand on sent qu'on a un gros rhume une
laryngite une bronchite ça c'est des
choses qu'on finit par un peu identifier
et savoir mais on pas besoin peut-être
d'un antibiotique on a besoin peut-être
d'un médecin non décidé et puis de
pouvoir le faire dans le cadre de cette
de cette téléconsultation en cabine
alors vous l'avez dit il y a une logique
contre de lutte contre les
désertification pardon médical dans les
Yvelines nous estimez que 65 % des
yvelinois se situent dans les zones les
plus fragiles en termes d'accès aux
soins il y a donc une réelle
urgence à déployer la télémédecine ce
dispositif inquiète cependant certains
yvelinois il y en a beaucoup qui
préfèrent avoir un médecin généraliste
récurrent ou d'autres qui préfèrent tout
simplement avoir quelqu'un en face d'eux
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut les
rassurer justement face à cette
télémédecine à cette cabine alors la
cabine me répète un tout petit peu mais
viens en complément donc l'idéal bien
sûr c'est de pouvoir trouver un
rendez-vous mais qui sera peut-être pas
très rapide dans une maison médicale de
proximité peut-être peut-être même quand
vous êtes dans un lieu reculé peut-être
à 20 minutes
de chez vous mais le problème c'est
voilà le délai dans lequel vous allez
pouvoir rencontrer ou avoir ce contact
avec le médecin et pouvoir voilà vous
débarrasser de votre problème si vous
savez que votre problème est bien sûr
immédiat et c'est le cas des petites
affections généralement il faut
immédiatement les soigner et puis cinq
dix jours après c'est fini donc ça elles
seront implantées dans les coins les
plus
urgents bien entendu mais c'est pour ça
qu'on fait ce test d'abord sur les sur
les 8 premières on va y aller
graduellement et graduellement dans des
zones justement de l'intervention
prioritaire c'est là où sont les
fameuses 65% dont vous parliez alors
pour l'instant justement elles sont
installées à Rambouillet Mantes-la-Ville
Mantes-la-Jolie Saint-Germain-en-Laye
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
Chanteloup-les-Vignes Meulan en Yvelines
ou encore Les Mureaux d'autres cabines
vous l'avez dit vont être déployés 50 au
total seront dénombrés dans les Yvelines
alors où est-ce qu'on pourra retrouver
justement dans quelle zone on pourra les
retrouver approximativement ces autres
télémédecines c'est 50 cabines de
télémédecine alors dans différents on a
un appel à projet qui qui m'appelle la
candidature plutôt qui qui a été lancé
pour que et qui se terminait d'ailleurs
fin janvier pour les premières que nous
mettrons en place après ces 8 ça peut
être dans une commune ça peut être ni
dans une dans une
une maison ça peut être dans une
entreprise même en tout un peu tout à
fait imaginé si c'est un lieu facile
d'accès fortement fréquenté et
qui peut aussi être
une cabine qui ne fonctionne pas toute
seule il faut quand même désinfecter les
instruments entre chaque entre entre
deux entre deux patients donc bon c'est
un exemple donc faut quand même
quelqu'un qui a déjà une fonction
d'accueil autre dans le bâtiment en
question et qui en même temps va va
aussi servir d'assistant aux personnes
qui viennent effectivement en cabines de
télémédecine alors pour les pour aller
dans une cabine il faut
il faut en fait bien sûr aussi prendre
rendez-vous
alors si je pense qu'il y a la
possibilité je n'ai pas encore puisqu'on
n'a pas les premières vont fonctionner
dans le dans le dans le mois qui
viennent je pense que s'il n'y a
personne et que là on doit pouvoir y
accéder comme ça profondément mais
autrement il est préférable de prendre
la précaution sur sur un site sur un
parc site internet tout de suite voir
quel rendez-vous on peut prendre et quel
est le plus rapide possible comme on
peut voir alors celle la plus proche de
chez vous puis après vous allez de plus
en plus loin si si c'est nécessaire
surtout en ce moment où il y en aura pas
encore beaucoup mais après on courira
justement le but c'est de couvrir
suffisamment le territoire pour que y
est il y avait le maximum et il y en a
50 qui sont en commande auprès de de
H4D pardon et je rappelle notamment que
justement les médecins qui seront donc
derrière c'est c'était les médecines
seront Yves Linois vous l'avez dit en
début d'émission en priorité ainsi les
noix sont débordés à l'instant t on se
dit d'en avoir quand même un peu
d'Eure-et-Loir où ou des Hauts-de-Seine
ou Simpson et c'est important de le
souligner merci beaucoup Laurent Richard
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation donc
je rappelle que vous êtes vice-président
du conseil départemental des Yvelines
délégués à la santé et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]